is even still baiting when there's
really nothing on the hook so I find
myself tumbling down a little bit of a
rabbit hole today I'm sort of following
up on I'm not sure it was a suggestion
but a notion that was put into my head
from a commenter about a week ago or so
who kind of asked about my opinions on
what had been said about the character
of Lando Calrissian Lando Calrissian in
the upcoming solo film you know solo a
Star Wars story and at the time I I
actually I replied to this comment cuz I
do sometimes and I said no I'm not sure
that I'm gonna have anything to say
about that but then I dug into a little
more cuz it had started worming its way
into my head and then I started looking
at the bigger picture of this trend that
I don't even know what to call yet and
I'll explain why in a minute but digging
into him or realizing how long it's been
going on I've now transitioned from huh
yes that's a little annoying to being
genuinely kinda ticked so yeah I'm gonna
be talking about LGBTQ representation in
pop culture so I'm sure the comment
sections gonna be great on this and just
because occasionally I do still get
people asking what's with the ring let's
be as unambiguous about this as I
possibly can be
so reiterating for the folks in the back
my name is Nathaniel
I am queer I have a fluid sense of
gender I have a dog in this race so
let's talk about this let's start with
the thing that actually kicked out odd
this whole thing off of my head last
let's start I'll be going a lot of other
places but let's start with Lando
Calrissian in solo so what was said
Jonathan Caston co-writer of the film he
wrote it with lawrence kasdan his father
who is kind of a luminary of the Star
Wars universe because he was the writer
on Empire Strikes Back but he was asked
about Lando's sexuality because he of
course has an in
the nation to flirt with basically
everybody and Kasdan's words were I want
I I have notes on this because I I don't
want to be paraphrasing I want to deal
with people's exact words on this so his
words were that in were in reference to
lando calrissian sexuality is that there
is a fluidity to it now that was sort of
framed in various write-ups as Lando
being pansexual and that may or may not
have been what Kazon meant some other
things he said in the same statement
seemed to indicate that way he talked
about LGBTQ representation sounds all
well and good except apparently the
movie doesn't really back it up now I
say that not having actually seen the
film it's not out where I am yet so I
haven't seen it at the time of recording
and if it turns out that my book into
this was completely wrong I'll mention
that when I do my review of that film
but I have dug into people who have seen
the film and who addressed this specific
aspect and it's not backed up he's
flirty with non female characters sure
he appears to possibly even be flirty
towards Han Solo and there I guess
specifically there's a comment from l3
his droid
but as Lawrence Kasdan Jonathan cousin's
father and the co-writer himself points
out it's not entirely clear if that's l3
kind of poking fun at Lando and being a
bit of a jerk because apparently that's
a Latrese character we're getting our
second jerk droid after k2 so it's not
backed up
it's not backed up firmly despite the
fact that one of the writers is talking
as if it is made explicit in the film
now I don't know how many of you folks
are familiar with the term queerbaiting
and historically what that's usually
referred to is movies TV shows that kind
of tease and hint at a romantic
relationship between
two same-sex characters usually two men
that's been the more common so there
were folks who accused the BBC show
Sherlock of queerbaiting and sort of
hinting at more than just a friendship
between Sherlock and Watson but also
never doing anything with it there's
been accusations of queerbaiting with
Bucky and cap in the MCU with Poe and
Finn in Star Wars and so on and so on
and so on so it goes back aways and you
so you get those kinds of accusations
where they're basically almost
encouraging fans to like imagine that
that's the case without actually putting
it in the in the product itself I don't
even want to call what's going on with
solo and some of the other stuff I'm
about to talk about queerbaiting because
this in my mind is worse we're baiting
is something that at least in the
classic example some of them and the
ones I mentioned and and others like
them they that is something where they
just kind of the makers just kind of let
fandom run rampant and maybe nudge it in
a certain way you know in order to
ingratiate itself to a certain
demographic of the audience and I'm not
gonna say that's okay but this is worse
in my mind because this is somebody
associated with the film saying
explicitly yes this is the case but it's
not explicit in the work itself and this
is this is the latest example it's not
the only one let's talk about the big
one one that I've actually talked about
before and if I've figured out how to do
this properly they'll even be a fun
little link there to when I have talked
about it before Dumbledore in fantastic
beasts because we've got that coming up
and it was confirmed that his being gay
which is something JK Riley has said
since 2008 so it's been on the record
from her for a decade now that
Dumbledore is gay and she always
intended him to be gay that it's not
going to appear in the film where he
appears as a young man and is in a film
along with the character that he
had romantic feelings towards and I've
done a whole video talking about that so
I don't want to dwell on that too much
but that's another example and this one
I think possibly the most egregious but
I am going to talk about some others
because this is one where the writer has
said and you know what I'm not even mad
at her for not making it clear in the
Harry Potter books themselves because
honestly aside from Snape we don't get
into the sexual history of any of the
professors and the only reason it comes
up for Snape is because his pining after
Lily Harry's mother is kind of an
important plot point and motivator for
why he does things we don't really get
into the sexual history inclination of
any of the other professors because
that's not the story being told is being
told about the students through the eyes
of the students and they wouldn't know
this stuff about their professors so I
was fine with that but we're now we're
actually doing it the story's weird
humble it's much more explicitly about
Dumbledore and we're still not doing it
you said it was this thing and you won't
back it up
want some more examples because I've got
more let's see here ah yes Wonder Woman
in 2016 writer Greg Rucka who was the at
time current writer on Wonder Woman said
that Wonder Woman was bisexual that it
makes logical sense and there was a
whole no explosion of news one woman is
canonically queer no she's not no she's
not because it still has not been made
explicit in the main continuity of DC
Comics has she has she been hinted at
being queer yeah since she was first
being written in the forties she's been
into that being queer hinted is not
explicit and has she ever been shown to
be explicitly queer
yes not main continuity great Morrison
wrote her as explicitly queer in earth
one but that's uh that's the multiverse
that's an alternate timeline that is not
the main continuity that is not
something that actually has to be
accepted or dealt with by
even DC itself as a whole or fans as an
entity so he said two years ago yeah
she's clear and we've seen nothing since
then now if you want to argue to me that
it's in his mind writing and that
regardless of what he thinks DC would
not let him make it explicit I'm even
prepared to believe that but if DC won't
let him put it in the work and he's not
going to say that DC is not letting him
put it in there I would rather he just
keep his mouth shut because it's not
helping and and that's what's
infuriating about all this it's being
presented as a publicity thing as a way
to do garner favoritism as a way to
score brownie points because you're
you're looking at LGBTQ fans readers
audiences allies and going yeah we know
we got your back yeah yeah no yeah you
know we know right right no we don't
because you won't say it and the failure
of these various entities to say it and
make it explicit and make it text not
subtext but text it's not okay and you
you don't get points for that you
shouldn't get points for that fine you
should be getting demerits for that ten
points from Gryffindor gone you don't
get to bank goodwill from a population
that you will not truly put out and make
explicit as being part of your universe
you say all these things behind scenes
oh is in my mind while writing it oh
yeah well you know I could I can't say
it but you know it's there you know what
you're doing when you do that you're
putting us in the closet
we're gonna closet enough all on our own
you don't need to put us in the closet
by proxy you don't need to put
characters that you're saying or like us
in the closet because that's what you're
doing if you're saying oh yeah sure
they're LGBTQ but you're not putting it
in the work cuz until it's in the work
then it's not real because I've talked
about authorial intent before you can
intend all you want for a character to
be gay to be lesbian to be queer to be
questioning to be whatever but if you
don't put it in some way explicit it no
one no reader no future writer
nobody is under any obligation to
actually acknowledge or deal with it
they can choose to ignore it for as long
as it's not explicit and there are
examples of doing it right but before we
get to that I've got more for you so
sticking with the Star Wars Admiral hold
Oh played by Laura Dern in the last Jedi
she boy this one ticked me off because
obviously she was visually coded queer
with the purple hair and I am you know
there was certain stripes of media who
are like total SW tumblr babe and there
was also in a novel and again big deal
was made about this you know there was a
novel where it was hinted at that she
might be some variety of LGBTQ but first
off not let their own secondly even if
you want to tell me about the novel in
which this little snippet appears is
canonical which I believe it's supposed
to be even that is not explicit it's a
conversation that she has with Leia
about romantic entanglements and you can
possibly read it as her implying that
she has an interest
beyond the male gender but honestly
reading the thing it reads more like she
is expressing an open-mindedness beyond
the human species because she's naming
alternate species and then it's hinted
that maybe the next thing she was about
to say was that she also had an interest
in women but she doesn't finish that
sentence leg cuts off and says something
else so again at best it's implied its
subtext it's a novel it's not even the
film it's the thing a minority of people
are ever gonna see and you still won't
confirm it
one other how about 2012 headline Green
Lantern is gay
no it wasn't Green Lantern to most
people's up mind if they know if the
character is at all it's Hal Jordan it's
Jon Stewart maybe it's Kyle Rayner maybe
if you're a very particularly odd stripe
of Fame maybe this guy Gardner know most
people don't think of first or second or
probably even third Alan Scott the
technically original Green Lantern so it
wasn't any of the current real Anders
who was revealed to be gay it was the
Green Lantern that is the least
well-known and it wasn't even the actual
version of him
it was it was the earth-2 version of him
so again alternate reality not the main
continuity not Canon messing about
elsewhere and everyone can ignore it
doesn't like it you get a brief little
pop you get a little oh that's great
from people who are dying for
representation cuddly we do have
representation we do but we want actual
representation that matters not
alternate universe representation that
can be ignored and not implied
representation which at this point is
just being worthless as far as I'm
concerned
now is that to say that you can never
imply that it must always be explicit no
I'll give you an example of a case where
a character's status as non hetero is
only implied but I am totally okay with
it
How to Train Your Dragon to the
character of Gobber the belch he has a
line when referring to a married couple
I forget exactly what happens that sets
it up but he says something like and
that's why I never got married that and
one other reason now that line in of
itself does not make it explicit that
he's gay and that's the reason he said
that it could be any number of other
things the guy is already physically
damaged he's got an artificial arm maybe
he's implying that his junk is burned
off by a dragon at some point knows but
here's the thing it was confirmed by
both the actor and the director after
the film started screaming they didn't
make a deal of it beforehand they didn't
talk to the press about this wonderful
thing that they included and how this
this wonderful instance of inclusion in
their film no they just put it in and
people started seeing it and only when
people after seeing that line went does
he mean what I think he means and asked
did they say yes actually it does mean
what you think it means so if you just
want to imply and you don't want to make
it explicit fine you can do that what
you can't do is go on publicity tours
milking goodwill from from a group a
very a very wide-ranging diverse group
of people who want representation and
want to know that they have allies you
can't tell them you've got their back
when you don't not really and now we get
to the one that actually might possibly
take me out most of all
Beauty and the Beast Lefou in the
live-action remake of Beauty and the
Beast play by Josh GAD now I've not seen
this film in its entirety
I refuse not because of this because I
fundamentally have an issue with
Disney's live-action remakes of their
animated films in the first place I
talked about that couple years ago why I
hate that but I did look up specific
scenes with Lefou including the supposed
and allow me to use director Bill
Condon's exact words here the supposed
exclusively gay moment the foo is not
explicitly gay I've absolutely no doubt
the Josh GAD had him being gay in mind
when he played him cuz he plays him very
effeminately but at best that's feeding
it stereotypes effeminate does not have
to mean gay it's coded to mean gay yes
annoyingly but that's not anything and I
myself that's nothing more than a wink
and a nod there's a line where Gaston
says you know why hasn't a girl snatch
you up and this is your opportunity to
make it explicit he could have said any
number of things he could have said oh I
don't know I just don't know if I get
girls or anything like that that would
have been your chance to make it
explicit but he didn't instead it was
lying about they tell me I'm clingy
that doesn't mean gay unless I missed a
meeting and clinging is now synonymous
with gay that doesn't count
except of course I suppose
stereotypically women are considered
cleany whereas men aren't it's another
feminine trait so we're at the
effeminate thing again so at best you're
stereotyping but then we get to the
exclusively gay moment at the very end
characters dancing we're in our happy
ending and Lefou in the course of a
dance we you know there's switching of
partners
he finds himself dancing with a man and
there's a moment about huh and that's it
it doesn't linger
they don't pause there's no kiss it's
not even love whose choice to be dancing
with this guy he didn't go up and ask
him to dance he didn't seek him out he
didn't go out of his way to end up with
this guy as his dance partner it just
happens and he looks happy about it
that's not an exclusively gay moment if
he had had agency if it had been clearly
his choice as opposed to at best a happy
coincidence then you could claim your
exclusively gay moment and you could
trumpet and try and score your brownie
points for having a quote unquote openly
gay character and a PG Disney family
film but you didn't do that and what you
did doesn't warrant any merit any
brownie points zero and it's not too
late to fix these things they can be
fixed that can be done correctly Harley
Quinn it has been implied for years
Harley Quinn and poison ivy were more
than just friends it was first explored
in explicitly in DC bombshells alternate
universe but that doesn't make my list
of ones I have a problem with because it
was made explicit in Harley Quinn annual
number one after DC rebirth in the main
continuity we got this affectionate
romantic sexually charged explicit
that is a kiss that is a loving hand on
a face that is a hand grabbing on ass no
question there it is
after years of stringing us along the
way these other things have done we got
it we were given firmly the confirmation
because that's what we need we need
confirmation you can't just keep nudging
us and going I mean we don't have to say
you're right you know we know you know
we know know if you're not gonna have
our backs don't come to us for brownie
points because you don't deserve them
this entire thing is cynical infuriating
demeaning patronizing we should be happy
that we have this implied inclusion
inclusion is a wonderful thing inclusion
is a vital thing inclusion helps people
not feel like abominations be able to
look at a screen or page and see
something that they feel represents
themselves and the character that they
can connect with in a way that maybe
they don't see in their day till a day
to day lives can help them feel not
wronged in their own skin representation
matters representation is important and
web representation happens it should be
celebrated accepting when it's just
straight-up stereotypical in most case
that's its own can of worms to be dealt
with but this crap that is going on with
solo with Beauty and the Beast with
Wonder Woman
with Dumbledore that's not
representation you're not giving us
anything smoke and mirrors and you want
a pat on the back for it well you're not
getting it not from me
and I think increasingly not from the
public at large people are starting to
see through this I don't know if I don't
know how many people are as angry as I
am about it but they're starting to see
through it so either explicitly back us
up
give us representation confirm that we
exist or if you're not gonna do that
shut up I don't want to hear any more
about how this character or that
character is a representation of the
LGBTQ community when it's at best a
vague implication we don't need you to
tell us there's subtext we can find the
subtext ourselves that's what we've been
doing for decades
reading ourselves into characters that
are not explicitly made to represent us
because that's what we've had to do cuz
you won't give us real representation we
will weed into ourselves
mutants in the x-men monsters in monster
movies we will read ourselves into
whoever is the downtrodden or the
repressed or the character who is not
allowed to be themselves we will read
ourselves into that because we have to
until you start giving us something real
so either do that or go away
I think that's about it I think I hit
everything I had taking a breath
checking my notes oh oh just one more
I'll shout out BJ Iceman being confirmed
gay Bobby Drake from the x-men being
confirmed as gay well done well handled
and that was a case where technically it
was a retcon but it put everything into
a new perspective for that character
that was well handled it can be done
well it can be done right but if you're
not gonna do it well you're not gonna do
it right stop acting like you did some
great thing if all you want to do is
imply fine apply you all you want but
don't act like you did more than that so
there is my thoughts my rant my very
visceral anger at this next level of
queerbaiting that is going on so what
are your thoughts on all of this that's
oh just scare everybody off whatever
your thoughts are even if you disagree
with me even if you vehemently disagree
with me please do so respectfully don't
use pejorative terms no use personal
attacks if you disagree with me I'll be
happy to hear from it if you do agree
with me I'll hear that to whatever your
thoughts are as long as you can keep
them respectful drop something down in
the comments less talk about it there's
stuff to do if you like what I do you
can support me on patreon and help make
this show better and help fund bigger
projects bigger things I've got a
podcast to do with my partner called
punch like a girl I'm on Twitter I've
got t-shirts for sale all that stuff
links for all that stuff down in the
description so until next time friends
lovers
true allies this council is adjourned
[Music]